hey guys it's gig okay let's talk about
what hey guys this gig uh come let's
talk about hey guys this gig again let's
talk about ah hey guys it's giggle and
today let's talk about
Deepu no see if you haven't heard the
news that's been spreading around the
anime community for the past day Code
Geass is officially getting a sequel
called Lelouch of the Resurrection and
yes the louche is the main character and
a lot of people have been asking me what
I think and you know who can tell right
now who can really tell who can [ __ ]
tell so I think it's just the best
option that we all just remain
optimistic because it's just the best
course of action and you know that's how
faith that sunrise know what they're
doing because you know it's their IP and
I'm sure they wouldn't [ __ ] all over
intentionally would actually review Code
Geass and give it a 9 out 10 put a
[ __ ] cash your gear [ __ ] is this
person I mean why should we be cautious
when like the ending of RT is one of the
most conclusive endings in anime or
something and it's not like the plot
threads were perfectly tied up in the
most satisfying ways possible leaving
the decision of whether Lelouch was
alive or not up to our imagination no no
you're totally right there's nothing to
worry about from the flip flop barnyard
here I'm getting ready to milk Gertie
and I wanted to just give you guys a
little how-to on milking a cow
that's it at least there's one thing we
can all universally agree on we can all
revive the dead code geass memes now
boys whoa
yeah let's go what do you mean you're
absolute I denied Axl what store are you
in I have two soaps or and now a quick
word from our sponsor hi yes I'd like to
order an extra-large margarita pizza
please
just we've stuffed crust uh no I don't
want any extra kircheis were there
please but I just said I don't want any
[ __ ] extra code geass words all right
so a lot of people are pretty surprised
or pissed off though bring the loose bag
but in fact everyone missed the concrete
evidence that Lelouch was alive all
along you see a strong theory was that
at the end of our - it was Lelouch who
was driving this cart here now what you
didn't know is that if we zoom in on the
cart here zoom in a bit closer and just
enhance it a bit we can quite clearly
see that sunrise had planned this all
along and you know they were obviously
waiting for just the right moment to
spring this on us but hey that's just a
theory and anime thief
alright let's take a step back for a
second and have a serious talk about
this I'm sure that a lot of us remember
code geass fondly as the anime that
grabbed the entire community nearly a
decade ago and this announcement has
come with very mixed feelings some of
you are hyped as hell and prospect more
code geass and some of you are very
worried about the prospect of a
continuation of which I am definitely in
a latter camp don't get me wrong I love
code geass and that this turns out to be
a great sequel [ __ ] brilliant
but we have to wonder what the true
purpose is of sunrise making a
continuation to one of their most
beloved anime franchises whether this
was something that was planned out that
could actually properly work or just a
quick cash grab which considering how
well the ending wraps up everything in
the second season and how a direct
continuation was quite unnecessary a lot
of us are afraid it's going to be we can
only speculate at this point as there is
minimal information about it and
whatever side you're on it's best to
keep an open mind as yes this is
actually happening personally I remain
hopeful but cautious are the possibility
of this continuation Time Machine one of
the most conclusive and in my opinion
one of the best ever anime endings
regardless oh my god when I'm doing
writing in the middle of the season and
I would have preferred it if sunrise
just put a Gundam and just continue the
timeline without rehashing the main
character yes if it sucks we can just
pretend it didn't exist but I love the
charm of the original any was not
knowing whether Lelouch truly did die
sacrificing himself for the grace of
good and sunrise are you gonna tell me
that this epic end it was all for
nothing in the end 10 conclusion jibun
well more like Japan whoa calm down guys
I swear does he how this plays out cuz
they could suck but you know it could be
good too hopefully maybe meanwhile in
opposite world oh yeah more cocky up
with Gingka machines baby Oh exactly
what I wanted
see
the fish is corrected